we're here at CES 2012 at the Seoul
booth showing off your party in a box
this thing has eight speakers inside
including to six and a half inch
subwoofers so here's how it works you
take your Android device or your Apple
device like your iPad and you stick it
in the dock once you stick in the doc
you're going to get digital found out
not analog digital it also has bluetooth
so if that you want to sit on the couch
you get the analog sound but you can use
it by remote control there's a couple
other things too it has some inputs on
the back for USB so you can connect it
that way it also has a line in and you
can use a microphone and I hear they're
working on a karaoke version to go with
it so this stereo system is
omnidirectional and it has an hdmi out
so you can actually watch movies with it
as well so this party's not cheap it's
going to set you back about a grand but
they're talking about bringing up some
other versions that are a little bit
less expensive if you want to take it
you can take a camping you can take it
to the beach lots of possibilities this
system party in a box is coming out in
june of 2012